foreign
I was calling in because I wanted to
bring some awareness to other families
uh special needs families in particular
that may not be able to participate in
family vacations over the summer and
throughout the year really recently we
had a situation come up with one part of
our family where we were completely left
out of the vacation planning everybody
else in our family was basically able to
go and invited to go except for us
um the main reason that came up was
because they didn't believe that we were
going to be able to get uh my daughter
on flame because uh I guess they're
afraid it might be a stressful situation
my daughter has never had a chance to
ride on a plane she's never been in an
airport so
um
wow this could be somewhat of a
stressful situation for her
um she hasn't even had the chance to
prove whether it would be or not
um so because of that we were basically
completely left out of a vacation and um
despite all of the past conversations
that we've had with our families about
how isolating regular everyday
activities and planning and play dates
and things like that can be the fact
that our family had deliberately left us
out of a vacation without even asking if
we would want to be a part of it was
really really hurtful
um we were having a lot of trouble
kind of seeing our way past this because
you know your family is supposed to be
the most supportive
people in your life and in your
children's life growing up however this
most recent situation has kind of left
us at a loss of you know who can we
really trust and rely on
to keep us included keep my daughter
feeling included and always make sure
that you know we're together as much as
we possibly can be
um we feel like there's
no understanding and very little trust
left so we're really just struggling
looking for some clarity and a way to
find peace so that we can move on with
our family and keep them a part of our
lives
John there's a there's a struggle here
and it's really rough because we often
desire
the desire of others as our friend Peter
Rollins would talk about right I think
it's a schopenhauer quote but when we we
don't actually get to desire our own
desires but here's an observation I've
learned in my own life whether it's with
material possessions or with
relationships or I want someone to react
a particular way to me I want you to be
impressed or I want you to include me
these are desires that are legitimate
desires but every new desire is like a
new bar to my own prison cell in a way
and I'm not saying that you shouldn't
have desires
I certainly have desires right
a couple episodes ago we talked about
Anthony Demello and when he talks about
the two different types of desires
within sort of Buddhist philosophy and
one of these desires is I'm going to be
upset if I don't get it and that's
really where jyn is here
those family members even if they're
trying to upset you which I don't think
is the case even if they're trying to
upset you you still get to determine
whether or not they upset you
um is nothing harder than looking at our
loved ones and realizing they have opted
out of relationship with us
and you have to enter into a season of
grief otherwise you are choosing to let
those shoulds and those desires bury you
right and I think entering into grief is
letting go of what I hoped would happen
what I wanted to happen and just
accepting
this is what happened right and when you
can do that from that Ash is where you
build what comes next which is we feel
like we've lost trust you have we feel
like they've just abandoned us they did
and you've got to sit there and it's the
worst and it's uncomfortable and it's
lonely and it's from that Ash that the
soil is is fertile so you can start you
got to find a gang people that aren't
afraid to try you're gonna have to get a
community in a tribe that is not one
that you're attached to by Blood but
that you choose right that's the that's
the work ahead of you and so be it yeah
I'm a big advocate of just that that one
last punch you want to throw in case you
have a puncher's chance of getting a
knockout even though you've gotten
clubbed many different times in the
match and you're you're on your heels so
I don't believe you you need to fight
forever but here's one thing if you
haven't already done I might try to say
I might say to the family hey
it is what it is but I do want it on the
record I'm not happy with what happened
and I understand that sometimes you're
going to make decisions that might
exclude me sometimes I'm not going to
agree with those reasons sometimes those
reasons might be understandable but I
would appreciate it if going forward if
you're going to do that you own it and
be honest about it up front you look me
in the eye and say hey we're going to
plan a family vacation in a way that
does not accommodate the special needs
of your family we are going to
prioritize doing it this way and you
guys might end up being left out as a
result of that at least look me in the
eye and own it and be upfront and honest
about what you're going to do and don't
perpetuate the myth the illusion the
perception that we're all cool in
vacations is something we do together
and then I have to find out after the
fact like somebody who isn't even part
of the family's decision-making process
that oh you guys chose to prioritize
this and I couldn't weigh in on that you
know that's not only embarrassing to be
in that situation but it's but it's
off-putting and I would at least get
that on the record
to John's point however
part of what's going to make this hurt
so much is that there is this
expectation that vacation is something
we do together and if they're not down
with communicating honestly it might be
best to kill the expectation in the eyes
of your children and start a new
tradition by saying hey for family
vacations this is it's going to be us
every year yeah it's just going to be us
and we can hang out with the rest of the
family for Christmas and all those other
things but for summer vacations or
whatever this tradition is it's gonna be
us and then you don't have to deal with
what they decide every year and you can
just create your own expectations yeah I
just want to highlight how important it
is to like clear a list like that on
someone because we carry these lists and
we don't ever say anything and then it
creates tension when you're around them
so on the men's team that I'm on at the
very beginning one of the questions
that's asked is hey does anyone have any
lists to clear and the way it works
let's say that yeah it's like it's to
clear the space and make sure everyone's
present everything's good so what have
the way the um the format is is you
would say uh oh I have a list to clear
on so and so and if you're in person you
like go up to the man and you're like on
his heart like hey man I've something
that I got to get off my chest and it's
uh it's more of a bonding than it is a
um you know putting down or insulting or
like you know pushing someone away it's
like bringing them closer but basically
it's like hey here's what happened so
it's not like you are this type of
person it's just an observation of what
happened and here's how it made me feel
it made me feel X Y and Z and uh I'm I'm
willing to let that go and then after
it's after you let it go then the you
know the list is cleared and um you can
you know carry on as usual and kind of
get that off your chest sometimes you're
not ready to let it go and that's okay
too and if and if that's the case and
you say I'm not ready to let it go but
I'm willing to like clear the space
right now so we you know so we can have
a good men's team meeting so I yeah
clearing that list is so important man
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalist or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free